dee
ています
ます
はいみなさんこんにちは
はい私はハッピースポットクラブの代表していますで回も最後です皆さんにちょっと
質問があります
みなさんは今までに心の底から知りたいと思ったことはありますか
やす私はありますし委託って c たくって毎日
早く終わりの日が来ることを夢見て生きていたんです頭の中ではいつも変な声が聞こえ
てきました
お前なんか早く[ __ ]ばいいのにえっ
この世の中で自分なんか全然必要のない存在で明日消えてしまっても誰にも気付いて
もらえない
まだ小さかった私の子供たちの寝顔を見つめながらこんなんじゃいけないって思い
ながら
それとは裏腹に私が考えることは真っ暗闇なことばかりでした
これが私の子供たちです
10年前シングルマザーの道を選んだ私は
今ではよく離婚したいんですけどどうしたらいいですかなんていう質問を受けるまでに
なりました
まだ大丈夫ですかお宅は大丈夫でしょうか
あっはぁ
4頷いてられたんだよねあのそんな質問を受けると私はいつもこうやって答えることに
しています
自分でしといてなんですけどよく考えたほうがいいですよ
ああ
本当に大変でした a
沢山の仕事も経験しましたビラ配りのバイト
ラーメン屋さんの店員コンビニのアルバイト
塾の講師ひどい時には1日3つもアルバイトをかけ持っていたこともありましたその中
で一番つらかったのは週末に子どもたちを自分の両親に預けて描け
夜のアルバイト
あのラーメン屋さんの厨房でお皿を洗っていると窓ガラスの向こう側に楽しそうにお
座敷でテレビを見ながらご飯を食べるご家族が見えるんですねもう私は何で私ばっかり
お皿洗って油まみれになってガラスのこっち側にいなきゃいけないんだろう
ってあたしだって
家族と一緒にサザエさん見て笑いながらラーメン食べたかったんで
いつも夜中に帰る車の中で大きな声で泣いてました
っっ
でも
それってすごい矛盾してますよね私は早く死にたかったのに
それとは対照的に
幸せそうにしている人たちを見ると羨ましくて仕方なかったんです
死にたいって思う気持ちと
生きたいって思う気持ちって本当は一つなのかもしれないって
今はそんな風に思っています
まあそんな私だったんですけど実は7年前に人生に大きな転機が訪れたんです
私のおじいちゃんとばあちゃんです実は私はあの知り合いの人に紹介されて
介護の仕事に就くことになったんですねで私は13年間の家族介護の経験があったん
です
おばあちゃんはパーキンソン病だったおじいちゃんの面倒を
13年間もの間家で一人で見ていました
幼稚園も小学校も体が弱くってあまり
学校に行けなかった私はおばあちゃんから勉強の代わりにおじいちゃんの介護の仕方を
毎日教わっていたんです
おじいちゃんのおむつ交換は私のリアルおままごと
友達と遊べない日は認知症のおじいちゃんと一緒に家の中でかくれんぼをしていたこと
をよく覚えていますそんな風に認知症だったり病気だったり
すべて介護というものが私にとってはいつも日常だったんですね
これは私が写したお年寄りのてです私はおじいちゃんおばあちゃんの影響もあって本当
にお年寄りが大好きです
偶然
旗始めた介護の仕事は私にとって本当に転職だったんじゃないかなって思います
お年寄りと過ごす日々は本当に
物語に満ち溢れています
お年寄りから生き方や自分の在り方や人生について教わる中で私は日々自分について
いつも見つめ直す時間を頂いていたように思います
そんな風に介護士をしながら過ごしていたある日
その施設に障害を持った子供たちが日本に訪れました
障害を持った子供たちはステージに立つと本当に嬉しそうに自分たちなおもいっぱいに
ステージの上でダンスや歌を披露してくれたんです
それを見ていたお年寄りは手を叩いて涙を流して喜んでいました
施設で生活するお年寄りの幸せって何だろうって思っていたんですけどなんだかそこに
私その答えがあったような気がして
じーっと見つめているとそこで一人の男の子が私ににっこり笑って駆け寄って来ていい
ました
やっぱれたねー
もちろん私はその子のことなんか全く知りません
でもその彼は私に行ったいたねって言ってくれたんです
生きる意味を咲かせずにいた私はその子の行った得たねっていう一言で
ああ生きてて良かったのかなって思うことができたんです
その日私はお年寄りの笑顔と子どもたちの笑顔と自分がもらった一言を感じてもう
しかしたら幸せって人生の答えって
とってもシンプルなのかもしれないってそう感じたんです
そして私はそんな幸せの答えやシンプルな
生きるっていう意味を伝えたくってハッピースポットグラブというボランティア団体を
立ち上げました
お年をリー障害を持つ方達
親から離れて暮らす子どもたち福祉って世の中で呼ばれているすべてに私はアクション
を起こしていきたい
そんな風に思って私の仲間たちは
自主企画イベントを企画したり
障害を持っている子どもたちの施設やお年寄りの施設にイベントのお手伝いに伺うよう
になりました
これ何だかわかりますか
やっぱりなんだか見たことがありますか
これぶれー年なんですけど実は逆さブレーメンなんですね
私が書きました
小さいものが大きいものを支えている
逆さブレーメンのように私はこうして生きてきた中で
世の中で弱い立場だって思われている人たちにいっぱいいっぱい支えられてここまで
歩いてきたんです
そんな事を知って欲しくて一つ一つを
活動に落とし込んでいきました
そんなある日私にはまた大きな出会いがあったんです
児童養護施設の子どもたちに夢を語ってもらおうというイベントをやっていた時に
重度の障害を持った2人の青年がひょっこり現れたんです
これがその2人です
この日講演者として夢を語っていたグレーと無茶さんは
プロレス信州プロレス聞いたことありますかね
長野で有名な信州プロレスの代表です
その方のこの2人は大ファンだったんですね
でそれを見たくってこのイベントに行ってきたんですけどこの二人は
ひょこひょこと懇親会の会場にもついてきました
そして
グレーと無茶さんに俺たちは障害者プロレスをやりたいですって夢を語ったんですね
するとグレーと無茶さん私を呼んでいました高尾山ちょっと
障害者プロレスやりましょうよ
やりましょうよじゃないですよねもう私の気持ちはまさにこんな感じでした
うん
だいたい脳性小児麻痺で重度の障害がある子たちにプロレスをやらせるなんて本当に
無茶苦茶なグレー止めちゃさん
でもその時私たちは彼らからどれだけ自分たちがプロレスが大好きか誰だけやりたい
かっていう夢を聞かされました
そして彼らのキラキラした目に後押しされて
数字つ悩んだあげくん私たちは障害者プロレスのお手伝いをすることになったんです
彼らとの出会いから半年間練習は続きました
たくさんのボランティアさん信州プロレスの皆さんそして東京まで行って障害者
プロレスの方たちにもご指導を受けたんですこの半年の間でまだ二十歳だった2人の顔
はどんどんと表情が変わっていきました
this 2013年6月
私たちが企画する自主企画イベントで
ハピスポ広場でこの子達は
リングデビューを果たしたんです
その時の映像を少しだけ今日はご覧いただきたいと思います
me
ビール瓶
的なん
実はこの後この子達たくさんの人にまたサポートされながら私たちとは別な場所で障害
者プラです
すぷろれすす会という団体を立ち上げちゃったんですね
今でも2人は頑張って活動を続けていますこの出来事を通して私たちは時には人は人に
頼り過ぎるほど頼ることの大切さとそして思い切って動いていけば必ず夢は叶っていく
んだっていうことを教えてもらいました
こんな風に一つ一つの出会いが私や私の仲間たちの人生を大きく変えていったんです
実は先日この2人に
あなたたちにとって生きるって何言って質問してみました
この前その答えは二人が line で送ってくれたのでちょっと今日は皆さんに発表
したいと思います
実はそこにその一人がいるので何か声がしてますけど気にしないでください
はいっ
よく人に障害が治ったらって聞かれるが俺は直したくなんかないん
境界があるから今がある
狭い世界だって言うんであれば狭い中で全力で楽しむ
遊びたいから働く
障害者プラですが危ないって言うんであれば健常者のプロレスは安全なのか
障害があろうとなかろうと危険なものは危険
でも俺たちはやる
なぜなら楽しいからだ
楽しく生きたいからな
お越し商事
リングネーム生じアンダーソン
俺は障害者であるが障害がある
伊藤俊輔という人間を操作しているのが真の自分だと思っている
障害者だからではなく障害がある
自分を客観的に楽しんでいる
そうして生きていると日常生活に新たな発見が生まれ
全力で挑戦することができる自分自身にレッテルを貼って諦めてしまっている障害者も
多い
それは自分の未来の見通しがついていきやすいと思うが
なーんか味気ない人生になってしまう気がする
俺にはまだできていないことがあるん
飛行機に乗ることだ行き先はどこでもいい
とりあえず飛行機に乗りたい
飛行機は移動手段ではなく男のロマンだと思う
小さい頃から紙飛行機を飛ばして滞空時間を延ばすために色々と試行錯誤してきた
マイ漁を何メートルに興奮してきた俺にとって何十時間
何千キロメートルと飛べる本物の飛行機はまさにロマンそのものだ
今どんどん自分のやりたかったことに挑戦できている
これから実現したいリストの一番上に
飛行機で空を飛ぶということを置いて全力疾走していきたい
伊藤俊亮リングネーム春望と
ばなど
さあでは最後にこの写真をご覧下さい
私です
学う
10年前新痛くて死にたくてしょうがなくて生きる意味も探せずにいた私は今皆とこう
して生きてきたことで
毎日が楽しくて仕方なくなりました
いろんなことあるけれどでも障害があってもなくても年齢が違っても
一緒に生きて一緒に笑って時には喧嘩して
そうやって
人は人と生きてこそ人なんだと思っています
そして今度は私が皆さんに伝えていきたいとおもいます
やっと会えたねえってえっ
はい
今日は本当にありがとうございました私は皆さんが
大好きです
本当にありがとうございました